m
à
les voix des choristes succèdent aux
cris des supporters dans le gymnase de
l'europe à elancourt les choeurs de la
pléiade propose depuis trois ans un
concert de noël pour réchauffer les
coeurs des cinq enseignants c'est un
concert cas pour objectif de fêter la
joie de noël de la partager avec le
public
[Musique]
on
près de 90 choristes étaient réunis pour
entonner des oeuvres d'un répertoire
classique mais aussi des chants nouveaux
on a pris une sélection de morceaux
aussi bien dans dans un répertoire
classique des grands compositeurs cinq
sens mozart des gens comme ça et puis on
a aussi chanté donc la cantate pour la
paix qui a été
fait construite par bernard lallemand
pour célébrer les accords de paix entre
israël et la palestine en 89 et le grand
espoir de paix que ça a suscité
l'association développe les échanges
avec des chorales étrangères deschamps
qui dépasse la barrière de la langue
on a chanté ce le fait que l'amour quand
je change de sangles la même au fil des
années ont fait un petit répertoire
et puis autour de noël on dit que c'est
le thème de l'espoir la paix qu'est ce
que nous avons les champs et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut tous retrouvés en
colle comme on peut faire plaisir au
public
que ça soit varié que ce soit un peu
connue aussi les choeurs de la pléiade
présenteront leur second concert de noël
samedi 16 décembre à 20h30 en l'église
saint-georges à trappes
[Applaudissements]